[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu
sur TVfil 78 il les 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct en ce lundi 30 juin
les Bleus qui disputent actuellement un
8e de finale face au nigéa la France a
les yeux tournés vers le Brésil nous
allons donc sans plus attendre du côté
de voisins le ten où se trouvve Olivier
Manis calco et Jonathan vilman la
marseillaise qui vient tout juste de
retentir bonsoir Olivier bonsoir
Wilfried comment s'apprête-ton à vivre
ce match ce soir à voisin le Bretonneux
dans le pub où vous vous êtes installé
donc alors déjà Wilfrid je peux vous
dire alors vous entendez l'ambiance
autour de moi mais déjà je peux vous
dire il y a une cinquantaine soixantaine
de personnes qui sont déjà arrivées bien
sûr ça
va au comptegoutte puisque les gens
sortent du travaill vous en parliez
effectivement elle a été intense ici je
peux vous dire que tout le monde a
chanté à l'unisson la main sur le cœur
les gens sont très remontés j'ai à côté
de moi Sébastien le patron du bar nous
trouvons un voisin le Bretonneux
Sébastien comment vous la trouve
l'ambiance déjà ce soir pour l'instant
c'est un peu tendu on a l'impression
mais je pense que ça va vite se décanter
et dès que il y aura un peu plus de de
monde avec l'heure un peu on va dire tôt
dans la dans la soirée ça va se remplir
au fur et à mesure et puis l'ambiance va
monter dès qu'il y aura le premier but
de marqué ça va être un peu plus détendu
hein alors avant de parler votre
pronostique pour le match comment vous
la l'ambiance je vous demandais par
rapport aux autres matchs qui déjà eu
dans ce groupe il y a eu tris matchs
déjà dans la Coupe du Monde comment vous
la sentez pour l'instant c'est un peu un
peu calme comme je vousi dit parce que
c'est vrai c'est un peu tôt dans la dans
la soirée mais l'ambiance vite vite
montter mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
calme là mais l'ambiance on va l'avir
après vous inquiétez pas vot pronosti
pour le match Sébastien
2-0 merci beaucoup Sébastien et votre
pronosti à vous Olivier votre pronostic
à vous Olivier alors mon pronostic à moi
j'ai mis 2 je pense 21 pour l'équipe de
France on va passer ce soir j'ai à mes
côté un supporter si temps alle encore
allez-y allez-y oui un supporter Quentin
Quentin vous êtes venu avec qui pourquoi
venir ici dans ce bar je suis venu avec
tous mes amis parce que le pti c'est
vraiment le bar où on va tout le temps
c'est une ambiance pour regarder des
matchs qu'on retrouve pas ailleurs qu'on
retrouve pas chez soi et ça fait
vraiment plaisir de venir ici en tout
cas justement un petit mot sur ce match
ça vient de commencer comment vous le
sentez ce match des Bleus et un petit
pronostic pour terminer bah nous on le
sent vraiment bien parce que l'équipe de
France on l'a jamais vu comme ça ça fait
vraiment plaisir de voir qu'elle arrive
à bouger toute la nation comparé à des
années où ça marchait pas forcément et
donc on s'attend peut-être un 3-0 quand
même parce qu'on est chaud quoi merci
beaucoup Quentin on vous laisse passer
une bonne soirée voilà WF ce qu'il y
avait à dire pour le moment c'est que le
début du match l'ambiance va continuer à
monter en tout cas on y croit allez les
bleus allez les bleus Olivier n'hésitez
pas à intervenir priorité au football en
tout cas pour ceux qui nous suivent en
direct ce soir 18h lors de cette
nouvelle édition du 78 lactu en
attendant la victoire et les buts de
l'équipe de France voici les titres qui
seront développés au cours de la
prochaine demi-heure responsable au côté
de Luc châel Alain Jupé et Jean-Pierre
rafarin de l'UMP François Fillon était
dans les iblin weekend à l'invitation de
la responsable départementale Valérie
pcrè l'ancien Premier ministre poursuit
son offensive en vue de 2017 et la
présidentielle l'association Rêve
réalise les envies des enfants mal à des
fites ces 20 ans une journée festive
vient de se dérouler au château de
Versailles nous allons en parler avec
l'un des responsables sur ce plateau
dans quelques instants et puis 95000 €
c'est le montant des travaux nécessaires
sur la toute nouvelle piste de BMX du
vélodrome de saquanttin en ibline en
cause des manquements à la sécurité des
pilotes
Igor Bogdanov condamné cet après-midi à
10000 € d'amende le tribunal de grande
instance de Versailles a donc statué la
justice lui reproche d'avoir piloté un
hélicoptère sans licence professionnelle
et d'avoir falsifié son carnet de vol
l'ancien animateur télé de 64 ans cri
toujours à l'erreur judicielle il fera
appel l'affaire a débuté en 2012 lors
d'une demande d'autorisation pour se
poser en hélicoptère sur le parking d'un
centre commercial des tempes pour faire
la promotion d'un ouvrage avec son frère
politique l'UMP dans la tourmente mais
qui tente malgré tout de fédérer ses
militants dans les ivelines Valérie PCR
a réuni ses troupes autour de François
Fillon pour un déjeuner champêtre samedi
également candidat également présent le
candidat à la présidence du parti Bruno
Le Maire Antony r etodim moine était sur
place sur les visages les sourires se
font rares pourtant lors de ce
piquenique Valérie pécrè était censé
remercier le travail des militants mais
l'objectif de la députée des ivelines
est en réalité tout autre retrouver
l'unité je pense qu'il faut à la fois
nettoyer l'UMP de tout ce de toutes
toutes ces affaires qui qui qui la
salissent et en même temps il faut
renouveler profondément renouveler les
idées renouveler les personnes et
aujourd'hui cette réunion si elle attire
autant de personnes malgré la pluie qui
nous menace et qui tombe sporadiquement
c'est parce que et bien nous nos
électeurs ont encore envie d'y croire
pourtant selon un sondage publié ce
samedi près de 80 % des sympathisants
UMP
récl une rénovation profonde du parti et
près de la moitié veut un changement de
nom ils sont tout de même venus nombreux
sur les pelouses de Jouan Josas à croire
encore en l'avenir de l'UMP malgré les
scandales extrêmement déçu d'autant que
tout le travail qu'on a fait sur les
idées sur le bâtir un programme fort a
été battu en brèche par la survenue de
cette crise on va s'en sortir évidemment
mais on a besoin je crois de se
rassembler sur nos fondamentaux sur nos
valeurs
face à ce ch interne Françis fon est le
candidat déclaré à la présidence deump
Bruno le n'it qu'un slogan le renouveau
les militants en ont RB des divisions à
la tête de l'UMP RB ils veulent plus
entendre les querelles entre les uns et
les autres ils veulent plus de Guer des
chefs il veulent plus de petites
remarques désagréabl des uns sur les
autres dans notre famille politique le
29 novembre un nouveau président prendra
la tête de l'UMP d'ici là le maître mot
est clair redorer l'image du
parti 20 prototypes de l'habitat de
demain présenté à Versailles à
l'occasion du Solar d'cathlon des
étudiants du monde entier expose leur
réalisation dans leur cahier des charges
ne pas consommer plus de 5 kWh et puis
permettre la recharge de véhicules
électriques commment s'en accommode les
compétiteurs Olivier Manis calco pour ce
reportage inauguration officielle du
Solar Decathlon de Versailles après 2
ans de préparation les projets de maison
solaire d'étudiants ingénieurs et
architectes sont enfin sorti de terre et
le résultat est stupéfiant pour
l'occasion une cérémonie était organisée
en présence de toutes les équipes en
compétition présente pour l'événement
sylvia Pinel ministre du Logement n'a
pas caché sa satisfaction la France est
très fière d'accueillir le Solard des
Caton Europe 2014 et très fier aussi
d'avoir sur notre territoire des jeunes
qui portent justement cette ambition
cette envie et un immense talent 11
jours de montage ont été nécess pour
voir apparaître cette ville champignon
si dans l'ensemble toutes les maisons
sont prêtes certaines équipes ont pris
un peu de retard on s'improvise pas
bâtisseur du jour au lendemain tous les
projets est fait par les étudiants donc
on n pas des ouvriers professionnistes
alors qu'ils nous aident alors que des
autres équipes ils ont des ouvriers
professionnistes qui aident à la
réalisation de la et qui encadre aussi
les étudiants en fait on a comme délai
les dimanche soir mais nous déjà
aujourd'hui on termine la et après il y
a des petites choses à faire par rapport
au revêtement extérieur et on a terminé
à partir d'aujourd'hui les équipes
recevront une note par jour et par
catégorie Innovation architecture ou
efficacité énergétique seront évalué
jusqu'au 12 juillet par le jury composé
d'experts et je reçois à présent pour
cette édition du 78 lactu Olivier ber
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur de
l'association Rêve association qui
réalise les rêves des enfants gravement
malades 20e annivers aniversaire cette
année à cette occasion des animations
viennent de se tenir au château de
Versailles des enfants suivis à
l'hôpital mot avec leur famille étai
présents regarde le reportage de
Mathilde caberne et on se retrouve juste
après sur ce
plateau le temps d'une journée
d'habitude rythmé par les rendez-vous à
l'hôpital enfants et familles ont le
droit à une parenthèse cette fois-ci au
château de Versailles pour ces 20 ans
l'association Rêve a organiser une
journée récréative jeu promenade dans
les jardins et visit privée des
appartements du roi soleil en plus de
ces journées l'organisme a pour mission
de réaliser les rêves des enfants à
travers la France aussi fou qu'ils
puissent être les plus fous c'est
peut-être ceux que je trouve les plus
étonnants on a un enfant qui a voulu
aller passer de jours dans un
laboratoire
pharmaceutique c'est pas toujours des
rêves comme nous on pourrait imaginer
rêver aller aux Antilles par exemple non
les enfants ils ont parfois des rêves
très simple linda est la mère de Lan un
petit garçon touché par la drepanocytose
matthie quand à lui est atteint du
cancer du cerveau il a pu déjà réaliser
deux rêves mon premier rêve ça a été de
rencontrer mon mon jouur de foot que
j'ai préféré de depuis que je regarde le
foot c'està-dire Junin un un ancien
joueur de Lyon et j'ai pu aller à Lyon
et puis voir même toute l'équipe son
rêve c'était alors comme il aime
beaucoup tout ce qui est voiture vitesse
forcément donc il il aimait il il avait
voulu effectivement
participer au Grand Prix de Formule 1
donc à Monaco on est resté 2 jours 2
jours sur place on était à Nice et puis
on faisait effectivement la navette pour
pour Monaco pour pouvoir effectivement
assister au aux courses donc il a
beaucoup aimé en partenariat avec
l'hôpital mot de Versailles
l'association s'est installée dans les
Yvelines depuis plus d'un an selon ce
pédiatre l'association Rêve un réel
bienfait sur les enfants les enfants que
je suis
on profité de la l'action et de la
générosité de cette
association
[Musique]
et vraiment cette générosité a eu un
impact
majeur et c'était un moment de lumière
dans leur vie dans leur parcours le
premier rêve réalisé par l'association
date déjà du 7 octobre
1994 depuis près de 4000 enfants ont pu
réaliser leurs
rêves
on va continuer à parler donc du travail
de votre association avec le directeur
qui est présent rêve ça offre une
parenthèse à ses enfants qui sont
malades ça permet de les rendre plus
fort face à la maladie comment est née
cette cette initiative il y a une
vingtaine d'années alors cette
initiative est née je dirait tout
simplement par un père de famille en
fait qui a eu un de ses enfants malades
et puis donc il l'a accompagné à
l'hôpital et donc dans dans cet
accompagnement voilà il s'est rendu
compte que cé un univers un peu lourd
quand on y reste longtemps et donc il
s'est dit voilà il faut faire quelque
chose pour pouvoir en fait permettre à
ses enfants de sortir de cet univers et
retrouver en fait un univers justement
d'enfants je vais donner quelques
chiffres 37 délégations départementales
60 établissements de de santé qui sont
concernés c'est difficile de rentrer
dans les hôpitaux de leur expliquer que
pour que les enfants soient plus forts
aussi face à la maladie il faut leur
changer les idées non je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
est largement partagé par le corps le
corps médical ils sont demandeurs aussi
de ce genre d'initiative ils sont
effectivement demandeurs de ce genre
d'initiative donc après nous nous sommes
soit en contact direct avec les hôpitaux
comme le CH de de Minot à Versailles
soit avec d'autres association puceque
la solidarité aussi c'est la
collaboration avec d'autres associations
qui font le relais en fait dans les
établissements de santé et aujourd'hui
en fait il y a 60 % des demandes de
rêves qui sont transmises par les
établissements de santé un peu partout
en France combien de rêves vous avez
réalisé avec l'association alors sur 20
ans en fait il y a un peu plus de 4000
rêves qui ont été réalisés et puis cette
année en fait on va on a a 12 %
d'augmentation du nombre de rêves et
donc là sur sur sur 12 mois on en aura
réalisé à peu près 280 et donc on a
toujours 280 rêves qui sont eux aussi en
attente d'être organisés qui sont
prochainement planifiés alors ce qui est
très intéressant ce qui même formidable
c'est que vous restez en contact avec
ces enfants qui qui sont malades je sais
que vous avez recueilli encore des
témoignages même une vingtaine d'années
plus tard d'un des des premiers rêves
qui a été réalisé je pense à Margerie
elle devait rencontrer Patrick Brel ce
qui s'est fait et elle retémoigne 20 ans
plus tard et elle dit que ça l'a aidé
face à la maladie absolument alors c'est
aussi un message qui est fortement
porteur d'espoir pour pour tous les
autres enfants effectivement Marjorie
elle a réalisé le premier rêve il y a il
y a 20 ans et puis aujourd'hui donc elle
est guérie elle peut témoigner de ce que
ça lui a apporté dans dans sa vie et
dans son combat par rapport à la maladie
c'est beaucoup plus fort elle ce qu'elle
peut dire que moi ce que je peux dire ce
soir quoi c'est un témoignage qui est
qui est très fort al lors de cette
journée anniversaire pour les 20 ans
nous avons aussi rencontré des enfants
et nous leur avons demandé quels étaient
leur rêves prenez votre crayon c'est le
moment d'allêtre au Père Noël d'aller
voir des dauphins on est allé au
Marineland d'tib il y avait des dauphins
on a vu tout le Marinland et on a fait
plein de choses on a surtout joué avec
les dauphins les on leur a donné à
manger et tout ça d'aller avec mon frère
à Disney que tu as fait to comme rêve
souviens qu'estce que c'était
avec il y avait des hippopotames
tu as dit quoi d'autre euh un bison ah
oui des lions des tigres rencontrer un
un joueur de foot mon premier rêve ça a
été de rencontrer mon mon joueur de foot
que j'ai préféré de depuis je regarde le
foot c'est-à-dire Junin un un ancien
Jeur de Lyon de plus en plus de demandes
de rêve on a entendu ces enfants qui ont
vraiment des des désenvies comment vous
réussissez à réaliser tous les rêves
comment ça se passe lorsqu'on vous
soumet à un rêve qu'on vous demande de à
réaliser alors comment ça se passe bah
c'est très simple il y a une demande de
rêve qui nous est transmise donc soit
par internet en fait soit par téléphone
ou par l'hôpital et puis donc en fait
nous on regarde en fait par rapport au
critères qui ont été établis par les
fondateurs donc à savoir l'âge entre 3
ans et 18 ans et puis le le caractère
médical au niveau de la maladie donc
ensuite le rêve et les demandes de rêves
sont transmises à un profession
professionnel de santé qui est bénévole
bénévole à rêve et qui donc va reprendre
contact avec la famille avec le médecin
et puis ensuite lorsque que tout ça
c'est c'est validé donc on enclenche en
fait les démarches pour org trs très
vite alors voilà nous notre
particularité c'est effectivement on
accepte de faire des rêves qui peuvent
se faire parfois dans l'urgence puisque
le premier critère pour décider bah quel
rêve on va organiser aujourd'hui c'est
l'urgence médicale donc soit il faut
faire le rêve tout de suite soit au
contraire il faut attendre que les
traitements se passent que la maladie se
stabilise et au niveau du financement
comment vous alors les financements en
fait ce sont des dons privés 99 % des
des dons sont des dons privés qui
permettent de financer effectivement
toute l'organisation du rêve et toute la
prise en charge puisque lorsqu'un rêve
se se réalise il y a évidemment l'enfant
qui est pris en charge au niveau de sa
logistique et puis également un de ses
parents vous avez souvenir de de rêves
qui vous ont touché plus
particulièrement on été réalisé alors
après c'est eu ce qui est surtout
important pour nous voilà c'est que le
le rêve bah ça soit l'enfant qui soit
touché par son propre rêve puisque nous
on propose pas de catalogue de rêve
c'est l'enfant qui choisit son propre
rêve alors après oui on a moi
personnellement en fait ce qui me touche
c'est les rêves qui sont très simples
comme on a vu dans le dans le reportage
aller voir des animaux monter en haut de
la tour effffel marcher sur la plage ou
parfois des rêves très deis dire
d'expert parce queun fois on a eu un un
un un jeune homme voilà son rêve c'était
de de monter sur une dameuse sur les
pistes de ski et il connaissait ça par
cœur plus que le mécanicien qui
conduisait la donc c'est voilà c'est des
rêves vous avez toujours réussi à
réaliser tous les rêves jusqu'à
présent'est impossible pour
l'association ex non parce que comme
c'était effectivement expliqué dans dans
le reportage ce sont les enfants qui
demandent leurs rêves et leurs rêves en
fait ils sont dans dans une très très
large majorité très simple vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure queaujourd'hui les
structures médicales étaient assez
demandeuses hein pour organiser ses
rêves parce que ça permet aux enfants de
de faire une parenthèse dans leur
traitement ça veut dire que le
développement va s'accélérer encore vous
avez encore des possibilités de
développement de toucher plus
d'établissements médicaux quels sont les
des projets de développement de
l'association oui l'objectif en fait
c'est de poursuivre le développement de
l'association comme l'ont imaginé les
fondateurs à savoir permettre un maximum
d'enfants de pouvoir réaliser leurs
rêves donc pour vous donner un d'idée
j'ai vu quelques statistiques il y a à
peu près 7000 enfants en fait par an qui
sont diagnostiqués sur une maladie pour
laquelle on peut intervenir et nous
cette année on va en organiser 280 donc
ça vous laisse imaginer la marge qui qui
reste l'objectif c'est pas de faire les
7000 bien sûr hein mais et de pouvoir
permettre à plus d'enfants voilà nous on
aimerait bien aller vers 300 350 rêves
organiser organisé par an ce qui est
déjà beaucoup alors ce ne sont pas
uniquement des initiatives qui
permettent aux enfants de réaliser leur
rêvees on va dire seul de leur côté ils
rencontre aussi d'autres enfants
d'autres adultes il y a des échanges je
pense à cette journée et qui vient de se
se terminer à l'occasion des 20 ans ça a
été l'occasion pour les familles
d'échanger aussi elle aussi les familles
se sont peut-être reboosté face à la
maladie de leurs enfants oui absolument
c'est aussi le sens de ses journées
comme cet après-midi au château de
versaill c'est-à-dire que nous on leur
permet de se retrouver dans un dans un
cadre assez féérique et puis
effectivement bah les parents ce qui
nous font comme retour c'est que bah
c'est encore une parenthèse dans
laquelle la maladie n'est plus présente
et puis dans leur tête et puis c'est
également la possibilité pour eux de
rencontrer d'autres parents avec qui
échanger des euh également des
difficultés du quotidien qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer donc ils ont euh une
possibilité en fait également de voilà
ils savent que dans cet espace de temps
qu'on qu'ils vont vivre euh ils pourront
rencontrer d'autres parents que les
enfants pourront rencontrer d'autres
enfants et surtout qu'il y aura un
regard qui va être neutre on va pas les
regarder comme euh comme des parents
d'enfants malades ou comme un enfant
malade et ça c'est beaucoup
l'association Rêve qui a 20 ans cette
année vous pouvez aider cette
association il y a un site internet qui
va s'afficher euh comme tous les dons
c'est déductible des impôts vous ferez
une c'est une bonne occasion de faire
plaisir à ces enfants merci merci encore
d'être venu nous parler de votre
initiative de votre travail avant de
revenir sur les derniers événements
sportif un mot concernant le vélodrome
de 50 ans en yvelin malgré son
homologation par la Fédération la piste
de BMX a eu besoin de travaux
supplémentaires un sur coup de 95000 €
comment expliquer ce kak Catherine
suletto
95000 € c'est le surcout votter ce jeudi
soir en conseil communautaire pour des
travaux concernant la piste de BMX du
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yveline la piste
a été inaugurée en janvier dernier elle
a été homologuée par la Fédération
française mais elle a nécessité
toutefois des évolutions depuis sa mise
en service les deux rampons par exemple
été jugé trop glissant par les pilotes
et présentaient un risque en terme de
sécurité une résine a dû être appliqué
sur le revêtement pour un coût de 25000
€ hors taxe autre évolution technique
concernant toujours cette piste de BMX
des travaux doivent être réalisés sur
les profils des deux premières lignes
droite et du premier virage afin de s
sécuriser et optimiser les trajectoires
des pilotes une reprise qui s'élève à
70000 € hors taxe ce surcoup entre dans
le cadre d'un contrat de partenariat
public privé conclu en décembre 2009
entre la Communauté d'Agglomération de
50 ans en yvelin et la société
vélopolice allez sport toujours mais du
côté véritablement des sportifs cette
fois-ci pour sa deuxème manche le Fit
Days 2014 faisait étap à 550 an en
Evelin Fit Days et c'est un tour de
triathlon où amateurs peuvent côtoyer
les meilleurs mondiaux de la la
discipline Anthony Resche nous explique
tout ça si dans le parc à vélo les
élites se préparent au départ de la
course avec leur routine habituel cette
fois-ci il cohabite avec des dizaines de
triathlètes amateurs venus se confronter
au meilleur Cynthia participe à son
premier triathlon et prend peu à peu ses
repères on sent que ils ont
l'habitude ça fait ouais ça fait pro
quoi c'est pas pour rien ça s'est fait
petit à petit en demandant des conseils
à droite à gauche et tout ça ou pour la
plupart ses passionnés viennent de la
course à pied et ont basculé sur le
triathlon pour varier les efforts de son
côté sifan est venu sur le Fit Days pour
prendre du plaisir on est tellement loin
d'eux que finalement c'est pas c'est pas
ça qui va nous qui va nous faire avancer
sur la course mais après c'est toujours
sympa de les côtoyer effectivement au
départ après on les voit plus trop dès
les premières coulées les triathlète de
50 ans en Iline Fred belobre en tête
mène le pleuton après les 20 km de vélo
à travers la vallée de Chevreuse le trio
belobbre Pételle le brin entre dans la
zone de transition ensemble mais à la
sortie les premières foulées sont
difficiles pour le jeune emeriic Petel
qui cdera peu à peu du terrain pour
conserver sa 3è place au final Fred
belobre et Aurélien lebrin termineront
ensemble ce Fit Days après 1h3 d'effort
le parcours était vraiment sélectif en
plus il y avait de la pluie donc voilà
la partie vélo était quand même assez
dure à gérer et bon ben on s'en est bien
sorti bah on se sentait soutenu un peu
plus que d'habitude alors bah on avait
envie de renvoyer l'ascenseur et puis
bah de de faire vibrer un petit peu les
spectateurs près de 40 minutes plus tard
après avoir vu l'abandon de Cynthia sur
casse mécanique sifan coupe la ligne
d'arrivée plutôt
satisfait ça allit ça allit en fait
j'étais plus libéré parce que je l'ai vu
arriver avec la voiture balais donc je
suis dit bon elle est là au moins et du
coup voilà on prend plus de plaisir on a
même pas senti laaverse le parcours en
fait je connaissais pour avoir fait
quelques sorties en Val chuse et il est
sympa il est sympa en plus on a eu le
soleil pendant le vélo donc sympa ouais
et pour terminer ce journal nous
repartons à voisin le Bretonneux où se
trouve Olivier Maniscalco Jonathan
villman pour la rédaction au milieu des
supporters des Bleus Olivier je vous
vois avec un petit sourire on n'est pas
passé loin du but français on n'est pas
passé loin non plus du but du Nigeria
tout à
l'heure tout à fait Wilfried et je peux
vous dire qu'il a eu des regards très
inquiets là ça va mieux parce qu'il
vient d'avoir une occasion pour l'équipe
de France la plus grosse la plus sincère
occasion pour l'équipe de France mais
juste juste avant il y a eu un but pour
le Nigéria effectivement entaché d'une
position dehors jeu mais au ralenti et
ben il y a un doute sur cette position
dehors jeu à mes côtés j'ai un jeune
supporter qui a revêtu les couleurs des
Bleus c'est Cédric Cédric déjà pourquoi
être venu ici au bar c'est une ambiance
qu'on retrouve pas ailleurs ouais voilà
super ambiance il y a du monde et tout
voilà super qu'est-ce que tu penses du
début de match des Bleus on a vu pour
l'instant les Nigériens nous nous
bousculer un peu et maintenant c'est les
Français qui reprennent un peu le part
bah j'espère que ça va le faire là c'est
vrai effectivement on n pas trop le
contrôle du ballon
j'espère que ça va le faire ouais un
petit pronostic pour terminer Cédric 2-0
Benzema et Girou merci beaucoup Cédric
bon match à toi voilà on l'a vu avec
Cédric les supporters qui sont encore un
peu timorés un peu tendus mais si un but
français venz et bien forcément ça
détendrait un peu tout le mondeagerait
tout le monde c'est sûroup d'ambiance
beaucoup d'ambiance merci Olivier on
vous laisse profiter du match on va
peut-être vous rejoindre d'ailleurs en
tout cas pour le résumé pour les
réactions les réactions également de
Allemagne algée qui se jouera ce soir à
22h ce sera dans notre journal de demain
soir merci Olivier merci à Jonathan qui
vous accompagne également et Merci à
VOUS téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivi
excellente soirée avec ce match des
Bleus qui nous réserve pas mal de
rebondissement à priori bonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soirée